[Music]
today's topic
i'm ugly
[Music]
here's the thing right i say i'm ugly
and then people freak out oh abba are
you fishing for comedy no it's not oh
abba no do you just want us to say nice
things ab here's the thing right here
you have to understand
i've built my identity on the idea of
believing household and to be fair early
on in my life
i really was
there's no way around it
you can't justify all the rejections
i've faced with any other solution other
than i'm
ugly and i've accepted it it doesn't
bother me it hasn't sat in me i've
accepted it it's okay
i had to self reflect and know why i
don't like compliments like that
it's really comes down to when i was a
kid
and i was growing up and people when
they made compliments it was really just
a joke
hey you're cute thank you psych
you